now I'd like you to use one assistive
technology and complete a task with one
of your favorite mobile apps or websites
if you're using a Mac you can open
system preferences and then click on
accessibility
you might try and invert colors or use
grayscale or you could play around with
these other options such as zoom and
voiceover as you use one of the
accessibility tools I'd like you to
answer the following questions can you
find all the critical content can you
navigate the page or the application and
find the links that you want and finally
can you actually complete the chosen
task this will help you get into the
mindset of your users and develop
empathy for them you'll get a quick
sense about which products are
accessible and usable for most users and
which ones aren't once you've done this
task check this box to continue